okay let's have another crack at how big
Graham's number is let's start with
three arrow three this is just three to
the power of three bang bang bang that's
27 the arrow meant this number to this
power simple enough now
how about three double arrow three when
we have a double arrow we're essentially
saying take this leading number and
string it out with single arrows like
this and do it this number of times so
if the second number had been say 10
we'd have had 10 threes like this
luckily the second number was just a
three so we have a manageable three
threes three arrow three arrow three now
we know what a single arrow means so 3
to the power of 3 arrow 3
now we know from a moment ago that three
arrow three was 27 so we have three to
the 27 bangbang mmmm-mmm a bang that's
about seven point six trillion another
way to think about double arrows which
is very helpful is that you are building
a tower of this number of this height so
in our example a tower of threes which
is three high and here when you work it
out you go from top to bottom and right
to left 27 here seven point six trillion
overall so there's three double arrow
three a pretty big number
what about three triple arrow three well
just like double arrows created a string
of single arrows triple arrows create a
string of double arrows take the lead
number again three in our example and
string it out like this three double
arrow three double arrow three W etc etc
again if the trailing number had been
say 10 it would have looked like this
with ten threes but again luckily the
trailing number here was a measly three
so we only need three threes this is
what we're left with three double arrow
three double arrow three now remember
what I said about double arrows
representing that power tower so now
we're saying we're tearing this number
three and the tower is this number high
three double arrow three now we already
saw that three double arrow three is
actually about seven point six trillion
so that's our tower height imagine that
a tower of threes that is seven point
six trillion digits high starting at the
very top working right to left here we
are at the summit we have three to the
three that's 27 then down a step seven
point six trillion now and now we work
all the way down this epic tower
trillions of times the number getting
crazily big with each step down by the
time we get down to base camp here at
the very bottom we will have created a
number so big it doesn't even bear
thinking about
isn't this arrow notation amazing just
adding single arrows between threes took
us from 27 to seven point six trillion
to a number that seems beyond
comprehension now you can probably guess
what a monster 3/4 arrow 3 is going to
be this expands to three triple arrow 3
triple arrow 3 now triple arrows mean
three double arrow followed by this
chain
but now the trailing number that tells
us what to put here and how long the
chain is going to be happens to be three
triple arrow three and we know that
number is ridiculous
so this chain is going to be pretty down
long and knowing what these double
arrows mean we have to start
constructing another of these enormous
power towers but this time the height of
our tower is going to be figured out
using this beast of a number so let's
see how this plays out we start here
with three to the twenty seven already a
pretty big number but that just tells us
the height of the tower below how many
threes that are here but this number
just tells us the height of another
Tower of 3's below that and this
continues each whopper of a number
simply telling us how many threes there
are in the tower below it you keep
building down and how many layers do you
build down will this number three three
arrow 3 which is unimaginable in itself
so can you imagine how big the final
tower of threes must be after we've
iterated all the way through this
process can you imagine that I think
you're probably cat
let's call this monstrosity g1 is that
Ryan's number nowhere near it
what we do is we now take another pair
of threes and the number of arrows
between them is 3/4 arrow 3G 1 that's
not the number of digits here that's not
even the number of powers we're talking
about that is the number of arrows and
we've shown how quickly arrows can blow
things up beyond belief now we can't
even count the arrows boy that escalated
quickly let's call this new number g2
now take another pair of threes how many
arrows are we going to put between these
ones you guessed it g2 this gives us g3
then we do it again and we keep
repeating the process the huge number we
get becomes the number of arrows in the
next number and you keep doing this
sixty-four times when you finally finish
there you go
you have grams number
this is the upper bound to an answer to
a reasonably simple question involving
coloured lines between vertices on cubes
in higher dimensions that's explained in
another video by Ron Graham himself
check out the links that are on the
screen or in the video description but
this is such a big number the two to
that power and that power are kind of
hard to distinguish it's such a big
number